اكد تحالف ميليشيا الحوثي وقوات صالح
استهداف بارجه اماراتيه قباله سواحل المخا
غرب اليمن وحذر من تحويل البحر الاحمر الى
مسرح مواجهات ياتي هذا في ظل تصعيد بري
حيث كثف الحوثيون وقوات صالح من هجماتهم
على المناطق السعوديه
الحدوديه
كان هذا خبر حلقتنا نناقش فيما وراه ما
تفسير تصاعد عمليات الحوثيين وحلفائهم رغم
استمرار تعرضهم لغارات طيران التحالف
العربي وما التاثيرات المحتمله لهذا
التصعيد سواء على مستقبل اليمن او على
الاستقرار
[موسيقى]
الاقليمي سيطر التحالف العربي على الاجواء
اليمنيه منذ بدء عملياته في هذا البلد قبل
عامين ودعم القوات المواليه للحكومه
الشرعيه في استعاده محافظات عده لكنه لم
يعصم انصار الشرعيه من الانقسامات ولم
يتمكن من تحقيق نصر حاسم على ميليشيا
الحوثي وقوات صالح ولم يمنعهم من
الاستمرار في مهاجمه المناطق السعوديه
الحدوديه مع اليمن ولا في وقف هجماتهم
الصاروخيه على مناطق داخل السعوديه ورغم
ان قوه الحوثيين وحلفائهم البحريه لا
تقارن بقدرات دول التحالف فانهم زادوا من
هجماتهم في مياه البحر الاحمر وتوعدوا
بتصعيد اكبر في حال استمرار منع دخول
السفن الى ميناء الحديده ما يزيد الكلفه
السياسيه والانسانيه للوضع في اليمن
التقرير لناصر ايه
الطاهر صور بروباجندا باسلوب المحاكاه
انها تحاكي الواقع صدقا لان الحوثيين
فعلوها فقد ضربوا اكثر من مره سفنا حربيه
تابعه لدول التحالف العربي لم يقنعوا بذلك
كما يبدو فهاهم يتوعدون بتحويل البحر
الاحمر كله الى ساحه
مواجهات على احدى ضفافه هاجم الحوثيون
وحلفائهم من رجال صالح ما قالوا انها
بارجه اماراتيه قباله سواحل المخا بغرب
اليمن لكن تحالف دعم الشرعيه في اليمن
يتحدث عن هجوم تم بقارب مسير مفخخ اصطدم
برصيف الميناء ولم يخلف ايه
خسائر لا يعني ذلك ان التحالف لا يستشعر
حجم الخطر فميلي شيا الحوثي وقوات صالح
ماضيه في استهداف امن الموانئ اليمنيه
وتهديد حركه الملاحه الدوليه بل والامن
الاقليمي والعالمي هو اذا خطر تتمدد رقعته
يهدد هنا بحرب اشمل في البحر الاحمر سواحل
ومضئ ويصعد هناك على الحدود مع السعوديه
بل ويضرب داخل اراضي المملكه لا مجال هنا
لتناغم
الروايات تسمع من السعوديين مثلا حديثا عن
صد هجوم حوثي كبير على منطقه الخوبه
بجازان في الحد الجنوبي وتسمع من الحوثيين
وحلفائهم قولهم انهم سيطروا على مواقع
ومعسكرات سعوديه هناك لا يشيرون كدا بهم
الى قتلاهم
لكنهم يتحدثون عن مقتل جنود سعوديين وتلك
روايه يعطونها بتسجيل مصور يصعب التثبت من
صحته الحقيقه الجليه هنا هي ان الشريط
الحدوديه بين اليمن والسعوديه اضحى منذ
نحو عامين امتدادا لحرب اليمن بل واحده من
اكثر جبهاتها
استنزافا لا يخفي مراقبو المشهد دهشتهم
امام استمرار اذى الحوثيين العابر للحدود
فوهم البالستيه تزال تصل السعوديه او
تعترض في اجوائها لا سما بعد كل غاره
للتحالف على
مواقعهم دعك من تضارب الروايات
فالاطفال الذي تقوده في اليمن انه يتحدى
منظومه الرد الصاروخي السعوديه ويتحدى قول
القائلين ان ترسانه الصواريخ البالستيه
التي في حوزه الحوثيين وقوات صالح قد تم
تحييدها كما يت ح عمليات التحالف الذي لم
تضعف غاراته كما يبدو الحوثييين وحلفائهم
ولعل التحدي الاكبر هو ذاك المرتبط بمدى
قدره التحالف على فرض سلطه حكومه اليمن
الشرعيه وتلك شرعيه ضعيفه غائبه بحسب
تقرير اممي حذر من انها تتاكل لمصلحه مجلس
انتقالي في الجنوب تدعمه الامارات لعله
جانب من الجواب على السؤال الحائر المحير
ما الذي يعوق الحالف العربي تتنافر داخله
براي كثيرين اجند تان انتهت الاولى
باصحابها الى ما وراء حدودهم دفاعا عنها
وانطلقت الثانيه باصحابها نحو سواحل اليمن
وموانئه موضوع حلقتنا اليوم نناقشه مع
ضيفين من اسطنبول ياسين التميمي الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي اليمني ومن بيروت هشام
جابر رئيس مركز الشرق الاوسط للدراسات
اهلا بكما ياسين تميمي ما تفسير تصاعد
عمليات الحوثيين في هذا
التوقيت بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه لكلا
اختي الكريمه ولضيفك الكريم ولمشاهده قناه
الجزيره بالتاكيد نحن امام مشهد غريب
قليلا ف في الوقت الذي نراه فيه معارك في
حقيقه الامر لا نرى حربا هناك حروب متقطعه
هناك اهداف غير واضحه وهناك استئثار
بالقرار السياسي والعسكري هناك تحييد
للسلطه الشرعيه على نحو غير مبرر هناك
ذهاب بالاهداف بعيدا جدا عن الاهداف
المعلنه التي كان قد رفعها التحالف العربي
في حقيقه الامر ما تفتقده المعركه اليوم
هو الالتحام بين التحالف العربي والسلطه
الشرعيه وهذا ما لا يحدث ابدا بل بالعكس
هناك حاله من حالات الاستهداف للسلطه
الشرعيه
وخصوصا المتواجده في عدن وعدم تمكينها و
قبل ثلاثه ايام راينا رئيس الوزراء يجتمع
بقاده التحالف العرب هناك ويشرح لهم حاجه
الحكومه لتحديث الخدمات في مدينه عدن وهذه
مشكله كبيره جدا لا شك نحن ايضا امام حاله
من انهيار الصفقات الجانبيه التي كان
الجميع يامل في انجازها سواء من جانب
التحالف او من جانب الانقلابيين انفسهم
هناك انهيار لهذه الصفقات وهي صفقات سريه
بطبيعه الحال تقود اليمن الى غير ما يريد
اغلبيه اليمنيون والى غير ما تريد
المرجعيات والقرارات الدوليه والسلطه
الشرعيه ايضا هناك حاله من حاله الاستغ
فال اليوم تتم لهذه السلطه الشرعيه في
حقيقه الامر ما نراه هناك خطوره اليوم في
جنوب البحر الاحمر وفي غرب محافظه تعز هذا
الاختراق من جانب الحوثيين شكل خطوره
كبيره جدا على الملاحه الدوليه ولكن نحن
امام حاله من حاله التمترس الاماراتيه في
ثكنات خاصه منفصله عن المجتمعات المحليه
عن المقاومه الشعبيه عن حاله الالتحام مع
الجغرافيا اليمنيه اعتقد انا ان ما نحتاجه
في هذه المناطق هو ليس فقط التحرير وانما
ايضا حضور الدوله الدوله غائبه حتى هذه
اللحظه لم يستطع محافظ تعز حتى هذه اللحظه
ان
يزور او يستقر في مناء المخا او حتى يشرف
على الترتيبات الاداريه في هذه المدينه
وهذه اشكاليه حقيقيه انا اعتقد ايضا في
بالنسبه للمملكه العربيه السعوديه يبدو
انها غائبه للاسف الشديد عن التطورات في
هذه المنطقه ومنهم كه في مواجهات تبدو
غريبه حتى هذه اللحظه يعني في الوقت الذي
تكرس الولايات الملكه العربيه السعوديه كل
قواها العسكريه لدفع المواجهات عن حدودها
نرى ان هذه المواجهات تتصاعد في حقيقه
الامر هناك الكثير من مفاجات في حرب يبدو
ان الطرفين لا يريدون ان تنتهي الى حسم
نهائي بل يريدون صفقات وهذه الصفقات لن
تتم هذا النوع من التصعيد المفاجا مشغوله
بمواجهات غريبه سميتها ما هي هذه
المواجهات الغريبه المشغوله بها
السعوديه المواجهات التي تتم على الحدود
في حقيقه المملكه العربيه السعوديه الفارق
الناري الموجود لصالحها هناك كان يجب ان
يحسم على الاقل المعارك في هذه المنطقه في
في في الحد الجنوبي كان عليها ان تحسم هذه
المواجهات منذ وقت مبكر وتتفرغ لانجاز
استحقاقات ما بعد الحسم في هذه الجبهه لكن
ما نراه هو استغراق كبير في مواجهه تبدو
حتى هذه اللحظه عبثيه هناك استنزاف هناك
في الحد الجنوبي نعم ام اسال هنا هشام
جابر عن الحد الجنوبي باعتقادك سيد هشام
جابر لماذا لا تحسم السعوديه على حدودها
هذه المعركه ما السبب
عسكريا سبب عسكريا ان الحرب اعلنت عن
اليمن باستراتيجيه خاطئه جدا لم يدرس
الاخوه السعوديون للتاريخ تاريخ اليمن
تحديدا شمال اليمن ولم يدرسوا على الاقل
الجغرافيا هذا كلام يا سيدتي نحن من الذين
قالوه منذ اكثر من سنتين عندما قال الناطق
العسكري السعودي اسبوعين سنكون في صنعاء
منذ اكثر من سنتين وبضع اشهر نحن قلنا
ادرسوا التاريخ بكل صدق وبكل موضوعيه وبكل
موده عندما تشن دوله تقرر دخول بحرب
واستراتيجيه الدخول الى هذه الحرب تقتضي
دراسه تاريخ اليمن لا ليس لنا مجال لذكره
ان اليمن يعني بتاريخها يعني هزمت الكثير
من الجيوش والامبراطوريه العثمانيه هزمت
في اليمن قبل سقوطها ب 30 سنه جمال عبد
الناصر رحمه الله يعني اعتبر خطيئه دخوله
في اليمن الى اخره اليوم الجغرافيا لم
تستطع ان تتقدم اي ضمن الحدود اليمنيه لان
الجغرافيا حكمت ان تكون صعدا وحدود اليمن
في المرتفعات جيزان وعسير في السهول لم
تكتفي ال
ال جماعه الحوثيين وعلي عبد الله صالح فقط
بالصمود وب الدفاع انتقلوا الى الهجوم رغم
وعوره الجغرافيا وقاموا بعمليات راينا
يعني بدايه بال التقرير ان هنالك تطورا
كبيرا حصل منذ يومين تطورا عسكريا يعني
تطورا بالتكتيك وتطور
ب الكفاءه القتاليه راينا رزمه صواريخ
تطلق على الطائف بالستيه بعد ان قرت
المملكه على انها حيدت ال الصواريخ راينا
عمليات اغاره دام ت ساعات طويله يعني هذا
بخلاف العلم العسكري الاغاره سيدتي يعني
كود مان تسمى يعني تقدمت هذه القوات من
ارض اليمن ونزلت الى عصير لا يجب ان تدوم
اكثر من ساعه او ساعتين لان الطيران يمكن
ان يدمرها رايناهم يحتلون مراكز لمده اكثر
من 12 ساعه هذا دليل ماذا دليل على تطور
في التكتيك على ان الجماعه يعرفون الارض
جيدا على انهم اعتمدوا تكتيكا مهما جدا
انا اراه اليوم يعني عسكريا من بعيد هو
القتال المتقارب يعني كلوس كومبات اقتربوا
من القوات السعوديه في جزان وعسير في جزان
تحديدا اول امس الى بشكل تعطلت طيران
التحالف يا سيدتي 20,000 غاره جويه على
اليمن وهؤلاء لا يملكون اي نظام دفاع جوي
تسالين يعني الموضوع كبير جدا ويمكن شرحه
بكل صراحه وبكل موضوعيه نحن من الذين
قالوا منذ اكثر من سنتين وبكل صدق اذا
كانت استراتيجيه الدخول بالحرب الى اليمن
فيها اخطاء والحسابات خاطئه ولم تؤدي الى
نتيجه على الاقل بعد سته اشهر بعد سنه بعد
سنتين هناك ما يسمى اكست استراتيجي في
العلم العسكري واستراتيجي يعني استراتيجيه
الخروج باقل خسائر ممكنه لماذا هذا الهروب
الى
الامام هوس الذي حقق حتى الان لماذا
الهروب الى الامام ساتوقف مع ياسين تميمي
واسالك لماذا الهروب الى الامام قبل ان
اعود الى هشام جابر سيد ياسين كما شرح لنا
بطريقه عسكريه استراتيجيه جغرافيه المكان
وتاريخ اليمن في حروبها لماذا الهروب الى
الامام لماذا ليس هنالك اجزت استراتيجي او
استراتيجيه الخروج كما قال هشام
جابر انا اختلف قليلا مع الاستاذ هشام
جابر هناك قوا قواعد كثيره
تغيرت منذ الحروب الناصريه في اليمن ومنذ
الحروب العثمانيه في اليمن اليوم المملكه
العربيه السعوديه تستطيع ان تثق بان لديها
سند من جيش وطني محترف ومقاتل ومقاومه
عندها قدره على التعامل مع هذه الجغرافيا
الذين يقاتلون الى جانب التحالف هم ابناء
هذه الجغرافيا المشكله ان التحالف ليس جاد
في حسم المعارك استنادا الى ما لديه من
عوامل نصر مضمونه ويدخل من ضمنها الجيش
الوطني والمقاومه الوطنيه المشكله ان
التحالف يستهدف الرجال الذين يقاتلون معه
المشكله ان التحالف يستهدف الاهداف
الوطنيه التي يقاتل من اجلها ابناء
المقاومه والجيش الوطني الى جانب التحالف
الجيش الوطني والمقاومه الوطنيه الذين
يقاتلون اليوم من اجل استعاده دولتهم
مخذول من هذا
التحالف بالامكان حسم هذه الم عندما قررت
يعني سمعت الى ربما ا طلعت على ما قاله
الخبراء في تقريرهم وقدموه للجنه العقوبات
الم مختصه باليمن هم قالوا اصلا بان
السلطه الشرعيه التي من المفترض ان
التحالف برئاسه السعوديه دخل الى اليمن
لكي ينقذها من الانقلاب الذي جرى في صنعاء
من قبل الحوثين
وصالح هذه الحكومه الشرعيه المفترض دعمها
اصبحت ضعيفه وغائب من المسؤول عن اضعاف
هذه الحكومه الشرعيه وتها بهذا الشكل خاصه
اذا نظرنا الى المجلس الذي انشئ في عدن
ودعمته الامارات
السلطه الشرعيه السلطه الشرعيه اليوم باتت
هدفا مباشرا لدوله الامارات العربيه
المتحده وهذا امر واضح ومدروس كانت كانت
هدفا بالاساليب السياسيه عندما دعمت
مبادره جون كيري في في نوفمبر تشرين
الثاني الماضي وكانت هدفا عسكريا عندما
دخلت في مواجهه عسكريه مباشره باستهداف
وحدات تابعه للحرس الرئاسي بعدن وعندما
هدد محمد بن زيد الرئيس عبد الربو منصور
هادي بانه اذا عاد الى عدن فسوف يسقط
طائرته وهذه معلومات موثوقه انا اعتقد ان
السلطه الشرعيه اليوم محاصره واعتقد انها
عباره عن عهده مؤقته لدى التحالف ويمكن ان
يتم اي تسويه خارج السلطه الشرعيه هذا
الاستهداف المباشر للقوى الغالبه في اليمن
ولاه فها هي التي اليوم نراها مسؤوله عن
هذا التناقض وعن حاله التراجع في الوقت
الذي يمتلك فيها التحالف كل امكانيات
التفوق العسكري والنصر والحسم في في اليمن
التفوق نعم سعود اليك سيد سين تميم واعود
الى السيد هشام جابر لكن قبل ذلك ساتوقف
مع فاصل قصير نعود بعده لنناقش التاثيرات
المحتمله للعمليات التصعيد هذه التي يقوم
بها الحوثيون برا وبحرا سواء على مستقبل
اليمن او على الاستقرار الاقليمي
[موسيقى]
ايضا
من جديد اهلا بكم ومباشره الى هشام جابر
سيد هشام جابر كان قد اطلق معلومه السيد
ياسين التميمي عن تهديد محمد بن زايد لعبد
رب منصور هادي من
العوده الى عدن انا اريد ان اسالك عن
الدور الاماراتي لكن عسكريا
اي هناك روايتان الحوثيون يقولون انهم
استهدفوا بالسلاح المناسب كما ذكروا يعني
استخدموا تعبير سلاح مناسب بارجه اماراتيه
قباله المخا بينما الاماراتيين قالوا انها
انه كان هنالك مركب مسير مفخخ وارتطم ولم
تكن هنالك خسائر بالبار ج بغض النظر عن
نتيجه ه هذه المحاوله الحوثيه لتدمير
البارجه لكن استطاعت ان ترصد الحركه في
هذا الم ناء لماذا
برايك نعم سيدتي بدايه اريد ان اوضح نقطه
للضيف الاستاذ ياسين اولا السعوديون ليس
لهم وجود مكثف على ارض اليمن السعوديون
الجنود والضباط هم موجودون في منطقه في
جنوب السعوديه في منطقه جزان وعسير اما
الذين دخلوا فهم من القبائل اليمنيه ومن
جماعه عبد ربو منسور هادي وهناك جنود
سودانيون يعني وقد واخرون اتوا بهم من
اكثر من منطقه هلا في موضوع لذلك لا
يعرفون الارض جيدا السعوديون يعرفون ارضهم
حيث هم في جزان وعسير اما على ارض اليمن
فهذه صعبه جدا ومعرفه الارض ضروريه ومن
هنا اتى الفشل العسكري في اكثر من مكان
ثانيا في النسبه للامارات
الامارات خسائر قبل الامارات فقط للتوضيح
ياسين تميمي على ما فهمته منه اشار الى ان
التحالف قياده السعوديه والامارات اي بدل
بدل ان يساعد هؤلاء القبائل الذين يحاربون
رجال القبائل الذين يحاربون الى جانبهم
على الارض وهم في في
الجو يجري تفكيك او او يعني هؤلاء الرجال
لا يدعمون بما يكفي من التحالف هذا ما
قصده ياسين تميمي بالنسبه للامارات تفضل
اه صحيح صحيح صحيح اوافق عليه وهذا ايضا
يضاف الى اسباب الفشل التي ذكرنا الذين
يقاتلون منهم بعض القبائل الذين تتنقل الى
ولاءاتهم وليس يعني هناك وجود سعودي كما
ذكر على هذه الارض والدعم الجوي رغم
20,000 غاره لم يؤتي الى نتيجه عسكريه سوى
تدمير البنى التحتيه بعد 20,000 غاره وفي
اليمن بشكل عام ولم يحسم المعركه باي صوره
من الصور ثانيا الامارات اريد ان اوضح
ونحن نتابع يوميا الامارات تكبدت خسائر
كبيره وكان لها دور كبير في بدايه هذه
الحرب وهناك يعني احتجاجات او تململ داخل
الامارات على هذا الاشتراك نحن نعرف ان
الامارات قررت استبدال دورها على الارض
اليمنيه بشيئين اولا منطقه عدن يعني دور
بحري اي اكثر منه قوات بريه موجوده واكثر
منه اي طائرات يعني اكثر من مره سقطت
طائرات وسقط ضباط منها لذلك الامارات ترى
نفسها هي المسؤوله عن ميناء عدن اكثر من
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ومن هنا اتى
يعني هذا الصراع الخفي ثانيا يجب ان لا
ننسى يا سيدتي سواء انفجر الصاروخ بالحائط
او انفجر بسفينه اماراتيه هذه ليست اول
مره تظهر قوه بحريه هناك بارجه سعوديه منذ
شهرين تقريبا اصيبت نعم بعمليات بحريه
يملك الحوثيون وقوات صالح نعم زوارق
طوربيد هذا واضح جدا ويستطيعون فع فعلا ان
يعيق الحصار على ميناء الحداده لا تنسي ان
اليمن شواطئ اليمن 1900 كيل م ولا تستطيع
قوات التحالف ان تحمي هذه الشواطئ او تقول
انها سيطرت عليها
ومنعت الدخول لذلك عسكريا هذا يا سيدتي
صعب جدا وهذا هو الواقع العسكري سياسيا من
يصدق ان عبد رب منصور هادي يعني كل هذه
الحرب من اجل اعادته الى السلطه يعني اذا
فرضنا جدلا شرعيا وكرر ضيفي كلمه شرعيه
طيب هذا رغم انها انتهت هذه الولايه منذ
امد هناك شيء يسمى مشروعيه ليتمي يعني هل
كل الشعب اليمني يؤيد عوده عبد ربه ومسور
ادي لا اعتقد ذلك هناك ايضا خلاف ضم قوات
التحالف كما ذكرتم
على الاستمرار المرهه على عبد رب منسور
هادي بالنسبه لعبد ربو منصور هادي قرار
هناك قرار مجلس امن ومتابع من المجتمع
الدولي هذا الموضوع يعني وال حكومته معترف
بها من المجتمع الدولي من الامم المتحده
مجلس الامن هناك قرار 22 صحيح يا سيدتي بس
ليس لا لا صحيح بس ليس هذا الحل اليمن
فرضنا جدل النصف اليمن يؤيد النصف الثاني
لا يؤيده لذلك ليس لا هكذا تحل الامور
وهناك كما ذكرت خلاف ضمن قوات التحالف
يعني بين الامارات تحديدا وبين المملكه
العربيه السعوديه على دور عبد ربه منسور
هادي وعلى المراهنه استمرار المراهنه عليه
لذلك انا ارى يعني باختصار يعني وبعد هذه
التجارب المريره ان الحل الوحيد هنا اسمحي
لي انا ليست يعني مديحا انا ارى ان دوله
قطر كانت لديها الكثير من الحكمه ان تنقي
بنفسها عن هذه هذا المستنقع اليمني ولو
متاخره الى حد ما اليوم نحن امام مشكله
هذا مستنقع يمني الدخول الاستمرار في هذه
الحرب لن يؤدي الى نتيجه لا تنسي ان مساحه
اليمن
528 الف كيل متر مربع يعني 50 مره مت
لبنان طيب فرضنا عسكريا واستراتيجيا ان
استطاعت هذه القوات ان تسيطر وتحتل ارض
اليمن انما السؤال ليس المهم احتلال هذه
الارض هل تستطيع ان تبقى فيها هذا سؤال
مهم جدا قوا هم هم هم يريدون اعاده
الشرعيه يعني وفض انقلاب الحوثيين وعدم
الس على صنعاء يريدون كما يقولون اعاده
الحكم لل الشعب اليمني بدون انقلابات يعني
ب حسب ما بعد الثوره اليمنيه وتدرك ما حس
المبادره وكل تعقيدات الامر المساله انها
ليست احتلال انما اعاده الشرعيه على كل
حال ساعود اليك اريد ان توقف مع ياسين
تميمي لاننا اخذنا كثيرا من وقته ياسين
تميمي باعتقادك تهديد الحوثيين بتحويل كل
البحر ساحه البحر الاحمر الى ساحه مواجهه
الى اي حد يمكنهم ان ينفذوا هذا
الوعيد انا اعتقد ان الحوثيين يعيروا شيئا
من مصطلحات ايران هناك مصطلحات استعراضيه
ليس لها اساس من الواقع والقوات الحوثيين
هي اضعف من من اي وقت مضى والقوات المخلوع
صالح اضعف من اي وقت مضى هناك تاكل حقيقي
على الارض سواء على مستوى الجغرافيا او
على مستوى القدرات السل العسكريه الجيش
الوطني باسناد من التحالف حققوا تقدما
كبيرا ومهما التاكل هو على صعيد السلطه
الحكومه اليمنيه الشرعيه هذا بحسب خبراء
لجنه
العقوبات بالتاكيد بالتاكيد هناك تاكل
بالنسبه للسلطه الشرعيه وهذا بفعل التحالف
لكن ايضا هناك تاكل لقدرات القدرات
العسكريه للحوثيين واذا ك ولا نستطيع
اليوم ان نقول ان التحالف العربي في
مستنقع اليمن المشكله ان ان التحالف لم
يغرق بعد في المستنقع اليمني وانما يحاول
ان يغرق نفسه من خلال خلال الافكار
الخاطئه من خلال الافكار الجهنميه من خلال
الخروج عن الاهداف المرسومه للتحالف وفقا
للمرجعيات الدوليه هو دخل الى اليمن لعاده
السلطه الشرعيه واليوم واليوم يحتال على
هذه السلطه الشرعيه ويريد ان يمرر اجندته
الخاصه لهذا انا اعتقد ان نحن اليوم ا
انهيارات حقيقيه لصفقات كان يمكن ان تعقد
هؤلاء الحوثييين ظلوا في لقاءات سريه مع
الجانب السعودي في ظهران الجنوب حتى وقت
متاخر المشكله اليوم ان الصفقات لم تتب
فقط ثانيا التحالف كان شريك الحوثيين
وشريك المخروع صالح في اسقاط صنعاء في 21
سبتمبر نحن اليوم امام تحول وتبدل في
السياسات وفي الاهداف لكن اعتقد ان الموقف
من ثوره الربيع العربي في اليمن لازالت
كما هي هناك ارضيه مشتركه بين الانقلابيين
وبين التحالف العربي تب سريعا بعشر ثوان
الوضع الانساني الى مزيد من التدهور نعم
او لا لان اريد ان اختم مع هشام جابر على
الملاحه الدوليه لو سمحت لي الوضع
الانساني الى مزيد من التدهور كرا الوضع
الوضع الانسان الوضع الانسان ال الى
المزيد من التدهور لاسباب عديده ايضا ان
الحكومه اليمنيه لم يتاح لها فرصه ان تقوم
بدورها كما ينبغي والمساله عهدت للوكاله
الدوليه للاسف الشديد الوكاله شكرا لك
هشام جابر الملاحه الدوليه في خطر ايضا
اختم بنعم ام لا سريعا لان وقت البرنامج
انتهى للاسف والموضوع معقد نعم نعم سيدتي
نعم الملاحه الدوليه في خطر قال ضيفك
الكريم لم يقعوا بعد في المستنقع انما ا
استمرت هذه الحرب ينغمسون اكثر في هذا
المستنقع اذا اعيدت ما سميت بالشرعيه لن
تستطيع ان تحكم ولا تعمل الاستقرار هذا
واضح جدا شكرا جزيلا لك من بيروت هشام
جابر رئيس مركز الشرق الاوسط للدراسات
واشكر من اسطنبول ياسين تميم الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي اليمني واشكر متابعتكم
الى
اللقاء
h